Before we can extract the earthquake
data that we need for our app, we should
discuss the structure of format of the
data that we get back from the USGS API.
When we say format,
we mean to discuss the specifics of how
the data is organize or structure, so
that we know how to dissect and
extract the parts we need for an app.
Earlier in this lesson, we reviewed
some of the HTTP request parameters that
were available to us to
query the USGS dataset.
One of those parameters format
equals value allows us to specify
the response format or structure of how
we'd like the response data to be sent.
We opted for format=geojson,
which sends the data back to us in
a structure using the JSON syntax rules.
While there are other formats that
have strengths and weaknesses and
histories beyond the scope of this
class we chose JSON because this is
the most common response format used
by many of today's signature websters.
That's not to say JSON has decidedly
better than any other formats such
as XML.
Moreover, we encourage you to explore
other formats in your free time
to get a better sense of the design
intention, the strengths and
weaknesses, and
even the histories of those formats.
Like all technology the web has
changed rapidly over time in
various formats have emerged.
Rest assured though, the experience you
will gain by familiarizing yourself with
JSON will also help you pick
up on other formats quickly.
So, let's zoom in on JSON.
For the USGS earthquake API, we have
a format called geojson available.
Geojson is just
a special flavor of JSON,
custom-tailored to represent
geographical information.
JSON stands for JavaScript,
Object, Notation.
For the name you might assume that
is tightly coupled with a JavaScript
programming language,
that's actually not the case.
JSON well originally designed to help
facilitate efficient communication on
the web and hence it's title JavaScript
is really just a set of some
tactical rules to organize data and
thus is completely programming
language independent.
So, JSON can be interpreted using
any programming language of choice,
including the Java code that we
use to build our Android apps.
Let's start to learn how to read JSON
by looking at a really simple example.
This example describes a kind of shoe.
Let's start at the root left brace
which notes the start of a JSON object.
Everything inside it before the closing
right brace is its contents.
You can think of these braces
as the container of staff.
At the heart of the JSON's syntactical
structures as the notion of
key value pairing.
Syntactically, the key is on the left of
the colon and the value is on the right.
This pairing is simply a way of
encapsulating a tie or an association
between a name of our choosing, a.k.a.,
the key, and its corresponding value.
It turns out this is an important
semantic in programming and
computer science.
Why?
Well, this mapping or
binding of a key to a value
helps us recall the data layer in
an easier and more logical manner.
In other words, when we want to
pull up or recall the data layer
instead of having to remember all the
specifics of the data because in some
case it could be a lot of data, we can
do this just by using its tag or key.
Think of a coat check when you're
going to the symphony hall.
You might have dropped off a lot of
items at the coat check counter, but
all you need to do to get your stuff
back is to hold on to your ticket and
give it to the attendant
at the end of the show.
Let's look at a few examples of keys.
Here we have the string key size, which
references a positive decimal number,
which happens to be for
the shoe size of 9.5.
When we see a comma, this is simply
a delimiter to let us know that there's
another key value pair following.
So we also have wide,
which maps to the boolean value of true.
Then we have country of origin,
which is a string set to USA.
This key value is semantic and
starting to feel pretty straightforward.
Cool!
These have been pretty simple keys, keys
with logical names that map to simple
primitives that you've been used to.
Numbers, booleans, and strings.
But wait,
the key style maps to a value of what,
what is this brace here, there's
a whole bunch of other stuff going on.
What are you doing to me here?
This could be kind of interesting, and
in fact, this is where the power and
extensibility of JSON
as a data format lies.
Let's take a break, and
we'll take a deeper look at
the possible values in the next node.